the efficient productions 14 years in
research or is how to find binary
strings yes okay great so thank you very
much thanks for staying here until the
end so this is I'm going to talk about
joint work with Tobias Cassini who is
who's here and Nichols all in Copenhagen
and yeah to make everything
self-contained let me just start by
defining it problems so we have a point
set P it consisting of points X 1
through n n in some some space and we're
interested in pre-processing this point
set in such a way that's given a query Q
we can officially find the point that is
closest according to to some notion of
of this n of Q so this is the main
problem I'm going to be talk talking
about a lot of work in this area
activities with a slightly different
problem so Alex was also mentioning so
that's that's the near neighbor search
problem so we're given that not just the
query point but also the particular
radius R so this might be given even
before you start pre-processing the
dataset
and the phone from the slide the
k-nearest neighbor search is just the
generalization of the nearest neighbor
search where you want to report notes
one near point but came Kenya points so
I'm going to focus on K equals to one
but basically all of the things that I'm
going to tell you generalize to the to
the case where a case so this is a
problem with a lot of applications so
you can find applications basically all
over computer science I'm not going to
go too much into that unfortunately it's
not a problem that we can hope to solve
extremely well not like other kinds of
search problems and as Alex mentioned
this is because we have artists okay so
so that different ways of formulating
this hardness but here's here's one of
my my favorite so it's due to Williams
and I think developed a little bit more
by almond and Williams a couple of years
back so even so we're looking at a very
simple space so we're just looking at at
the having cube 3d dimensions and
suppose we were able to do near neighbor
search and just slightly soft linear
time so just end to say 0.99 a and time
that is also sub-exponential indeed so
this is kind of the the least we could
ask for basically so this is just
slightly non-trivial so it beats linear
search it beats kind of enumerated all
the answers yeah and suppose we could do
this with pre-processing time that's
polynomial and in and subbed exponential
indeed if that was possible it would
have a surprising cut the consequence
namely that case that could be solved
fast and fast here would be C to the end
for some C smaller than
this is a famous problem in exact
algorithms and there's a conjecture
strong exponential time hypothesis which
says that this is not possible probably
not possible so underly at least under
this conjecture we cannot hope to do
anything really non-trivial or you could
turn around and say if we actually do
something non-trivial then well then
we'll make progress in in differential
time algorithms so this is not just a
theoretical thing so in practice also
you'll refer to something called the
curse of dimensionality which means that
if you try to solve exact nearest
neighbors maybe using some kind of
search tree or something like this it
becomes very slow in high dimensions so
also in practices for practical data
sets so you quickly degrade to something
that is committed basically a slowest
linnaeus heart so what can you do to
address this well you can look at
approximate your neighbor so so this
paper is almost twenty years twenty
years old now by indigent motwani let's
start this to this line of study ok so
what is the idea here
suppose that the nearest neighbor is at
distance R then we allow a little bit of
slack so we actually consider a larger
pole and of radius CR and any point
within this larger pole is a valid
answer ok so this is C approximate
there's neighbor and the point is like
Alex also set in this setting as soon as
C is larger than 1 then you can get sub
linear query time and into the row of C
where C is some number less than 1 that
depends on C that's a lot of work trying
to get the best possible throw values
for different spaces but I'm not going
to go into into that so in practice ok
so this is us this is a screenshot from
a site called E&M benchmarks so it shows
all kinds of algorithms for nearest
neighbor search
so they also called approximate nearest
neighbor but what they mean is actually
something pretty different yes so on the
you know on the y-axis is is the the
speed so the fast the high up the faster
and on the excesses axis is a notion of
how precise it is but it's not about
approximation factors it's about
something called we call so recall is
just a fraction of nearest neighbors
that you find for a particular set of
queries okay so these benchmarks have a
predefined set of queries that you will
run all the algorithms and you see how
many of these queries actually find the
nearest neighbor yeah and this gives you
a fraction between 0 and 1 and you can
see that the higher fraction you want
the slower the algorithm yes none of
these methods except maybe at if you
want to get everything exact so if you
want to be here or here something like
this then there's a guarantee but
otherwise all of these points are really
just empirical
ok so they no no no no no real can't see
that that that there that you are going
to achieve this kind of recall on on a
new data set yeah
so there is kind of this discrepancy so
so we have theoretical work that has
approximation in terms of distance
approximation and we have these
empirical results that talk about kind
of the fraction of time we succeed in
in practice which is like a trivial
algorithm that just says just look
through all the points just to
understand where with your scale yes I
think this this point down here on the
bottom right is it's not not trivial but
it's some some kind of search tree that
guarantees to find the nearest neighbor
as far as I recall I don't think food
forces on okay yeah maybe that way of
the chart though it's yeah it's it's
hard to see here so go to any benchmark
um you can inspect all of these it's
it's a really nice site so you can you
can there are all kinds of nice
visualizations just keeps us are there
any of our favorite theoretical
algorithms in the mix that you can point
it out here okay so until recently I
think there was one library called [ __ ]
that was on there so I think right now
it's it's not on there is that right
Julia yeah but I I think it'll probably
appear at some point in the future but
well you you can ask you about it and we
also my my group is also working on
implementation so we're hoping to it so
at there but but right now an
interactive there is this stuff based on
theoretical work but it's it's not kind
of state-of-the-art
all right so what we would really like
is is to also say something in theory
about recall okay and one of them might
be a black box reduction so suppose we
just choose the approximation factor
small enough then of course the
approximate nearest neighbor would
actually be the nearest neighbor so
that's that's one attempt but I mean
that's this is this doesn't seem to be
the B would be the right way because it
doesn't really distinguish between easy
and hard cases so so for example here on
the left the nearest neighbor has almost
the same distance as the second nearest
neighbor so we would need an
approximation factor very close to one
the same is true on the on the right
hand side but that instance actually
looks much harder because there are lots
of points that have almost the same
distance from the from the career
suggests just having a black box
reduction doesn't seem to to give the
right answer in so what you can do and
what people have also observed that you
can do is that you can kind of unpack
this this black box and and you'll get
some of the method selector used and for
example one could could do this with a
this.h with multi probing so I'm not
going to you I mean I can explain in a
few minutes but is but I'm actually just
going to treat that an as an abstract
black box so it's some linear space
station structure it's basically some
kind of hash table that allows us to
retrieve data points with different
probabilities so X I is retrieval
probability P I and the idea is that
closer points are retrieved with higher
probability and let's just say that the
nearest neighbor is X 1 such that P 1 is
the probability that retrieve excellent
right so so we can query this data
structure and it has an expected cost
that depends on some parameters so
there's some internal parameters that
you need to specify called K and T and
then of course you have to look at all
the all the points that you have
retrieved so the cost is at least the
sum of the sort of the proteins is - the
expected number of points that you give
you a truth all right
and now I won't really go into how you
choose these these parameters but you
somehow choose them to optimize the
running time anyway
now suppose you have this what is the
probability that you that you fail well
it's it's pretty large it's 1 minus P 1
but you you can of course repeat ok so
suppose we repeat independently L times
capital L times what's the probability
that we fail well it's the probability
that we fail each time so it's 1 minus e
to the L and so if L is large enough so
it's it needs to be something like like
1 over Delta over P 1 then we have
probability 1 minus tales of succeeding
actually finding the the nearest
neighbor ok
so in other words we get with this
number of repetitions we get expected
recall 1 minus Delta 9 of course we
don't really know in advance what P 1 is
so I'm going to come back to 2 it's to
that but there's also this annoying
issue of these of these parameters all
right and this is actually something
that people you know were worried about
in in practice they have some datasets
they need to set these parameters so
what do they do they go to the
documentation of the software they're
using maybe they go to the Falcon
documentation so yeah so this is Cecilia
and what we cool in the minutes I think
everything almost most of the library at
least ok and it has some advice about
choosing parameters so it sits down here
and it kind of says you need to do a
parameter search you kind of try
increasing
use and then for each value you try all
the values and so on so it's really I
mean it's really an empirical task so
you have to look at a particular data
set maybe query distribution to to
choose these parameters in in a good way
of course theoretically you you might
say okay that's just probably lot
different parameter choices maybe we can
kind of try them all in parallel or
something like this but in in practice
any poly log factor is going to kill
whatever speed-up would get from the
approximation yeah so we would like to
do something yeah okay so something
that's that that adapts to the to the
data and also to the to the query so if
we have a query that is really easy
maybe the query is very close to one of
the data points we should be able to
find that data point quickly if the
query is quite far from those data
points we'll have to spend more time
finding the nearest nail all right so
one such technique and this is only
something that I discovered recently was
described ten years ago by dong it elf
so it's in a in a kind of an array in an
applied conference but there is this the
section does it that describes something
called a top to adaptive stopping yeah
so suppose that so we are searching one
one of these hash tables for example
using multi provillus H so we approved
searching one hash table after the other
suppose we have searched T hash tables
and the nearest point we saw so far was
is X star okay
so we would like to know if we can if we
can stop is it likely that X star is
actually already the nearest neighbor so
let's suppose we can actually compute
the probability of finding X star in a
particular in a particular hash table
okay it's non-trivial how how to do this
but let's suppose that we can get this
probability and let's call that P star
then it turns out that if T is somewhat
bigger than one over P star so if T is
so large that you would have expected to
see X star lock 1 over Delta x then we
can actually stop and return X and with
probability 1 minus Delta X X or X star
will actually be the nearest neighbor so
if you think about it for a little while
it's it's it's pretty easy to see that
this is the case so why is this not
quite ideal well it requires us to
compute or estimate this quantity P star
ok and depending on the kind of method
we use for multi provillus age this can
actually be pretty pretty difficult so
let's let's step back so what I'm going
to present is kind of a simple
alternative that is essentially s good
so that's let's just step back and take
a take a slightly more abstract view
okay so did so yeah so the the query I
went from the beginning we just know the
query and now what we can do is that we
can inspect one of the hash tables so
actually what is going to happen is that
there is some part of the space I've
drawn it here just as a rectangle and
we're going to look at all the points
from the point set that are in this part
of the space yeah and one of the point
is going to be closest let's let's
suppose it's a it's this one beta let me
go to the
to the next hash table we look at a
different part of the space maybe
there's a closer point in there and we
go on like like this sometimes we find
we don't find a closer point sometimes
we do and we continue like this for a
while and now we would like to
understand you know can we stop no how
can we know if better the current
closest point is likely to be the
nearest neighbor so each of these times
what you're doing is you're looking at
all the things in the same pocket yes so
so look at the pockets the closest one
is kind of the candidate from that
pocket and you see if it improves your
the previous yes all right and you know
if you look at this picture it kind of
looks like we we should be pretty safe
right because we kind of looked
everywhere an aside is this this ball it
it sees and but but in general you know
what what does it take to to be pretty
pretty sure that what we have found so
far is it's actually than yours yeah so
we explore this idea of confirmation
sampling so the idea is that okay so in
each repetition do we get some candidate
which is the closest point in in the in
the pocket number I so let's call that Y
I and we do this independently for each
I and let's let Peter I be the nearest
neighbor found in the first I steps so
now the stopping rule is that if in
repetition I we get we see copy number T
plus one of the best of the current best
nearest neighbor so in other words if
beta I appears t plus one times in the
candidate set so far
we stop okay so T here is just just a
parameter so in other words okay so we
get a nearest neighbor candidate beta we
see it for the first time and then we
see a team or x without seeing anything
that is closer okay then we say that
this nearest neighbor candidate is
confirmed T times 1 so P has told me
about this idea for the first time I
actually thought that it probably didn't
work until we realized that it did so
the claim is that the nearest okay I at
least if we assume that the nearest
neighbor is more likely to be a
candidate than anything else okay so the
probability that we let the best thing
from a hash table that that we look at
is the nearest neighbor is at least as
high as any other data point safer to
actually say that a particular distance
appears t plus 1 times in case there are
multiple points that are almost nearest
neighbors because each of them might
appear in first through this rule of
yeah okay yeah I mean 2 points with the
same probability or the same distances
is fine you just need a tie breaking
rule all have the same what was the same
is fine
almost the same is fine and actually
actually it only needs it only needs to
be the most likely also a constant
factor so it's it's actually fine that
there's some other points that it's
enzymes more likely just as long as it's
bounded by constant alright okay so
let's go back to the previous example so
we have our query
let's do confirmation sampling with G
equals to 1 we get a sample so this is
the best seen so far of course we
Beza we get a new sample which is
slightly better update pizza get another
sample we tone up to eight paisa get
another sample update and so on actually
okay so now we actually found the
nearest neighbor as you can see but we
do we don't know that so we continue for
for a while until we see the nearest
neighbor once more that's our
confirmation and we were to in beta so
very simple method okay so so why does
this work so suppose X 1 is the nearest
neighbor okay so I'm prior to trying to
I want to argue that the probability
that we return something other than the
nearest neighbor is 2 to the minus any
any any other that we return something
wrong is 2 to the minus T at not
so what does it take to return something
other than nearest-neighbor it requires
something called false confirmations so
it requires that at some point the best
thing we have seen so far is beta I
minus one and we see it again okay
so theta I minus one is the best so far
and then we sample the same point once
more in in the I hash table but it's not
the nearest name okay so we call that a
false confirmation and the yeah the
essential thing to observe is that all
that matters are steps where we see
either the nearest neighbor or a false
confirmation okay so if we sample
something that is different from the one
with the current candidate beta it
doesn't matter so these are the only
things we care about so let's see so
let's consider the first T steps where
we are a sample the nearest neighbor or
produce a false confirmation so I mean
so so this is the gist of the idea so
you it needs a little bit more more
weight to be made completely formed
okay but essentially because sampling x1
is most likely than sampling this base I
minus one the probability given that you
know that you either see x1 or get a
false confirmation the probability that
you get a false confirmation is at most
1/2 and this needs to be helped to
having T times so all in all the
probability of getting T false
confirmations and returning something
wrong is that most T to the ninth
and to make it more fun or say you don't
need to lose any more costumes no we
don't lose any constants to make it more
formal you need to split the probability
space into you know cases where where
these confirmations happens in which
steps these confirmations happen and so
on but in each in each of these case you
can do this analysis
all right so this is this actually is an
abstract algorithm so you can write up
like this abstractly so we have some
some way of sampling from from a space
and we have we're looking for for the
smallest element from the support
basically here according to two to some
order if we sample something that is
equal to the smallest element seen seen
so far we increase account of if we
sample something that is smaller than
the smallest thing seems seem so far we
update the candidate and set the
countess is zero and we continue this
until we have the cavity
so so it turns out actually as I was
mentioning before that this works even
if what we're looking for doesn't have
the highest probability of being saddled
okay as long as as the highest
probability is no more than a constant
factor higher than the probability p1 of
same thing what we're looking for
we get exponential decay in in T of the
failure points getting into the bucket
yes right I mean I kind of pushed pushed
that issue aside for now
yeah but we'll we'll get back to that
okay how long does this take
well I mean the latest time that we are
going to terminate is the time when we
have sampled X 1 T plus 1 times maybe we
get false confirmations and we terminate
earlier but no later than the time we
sample X 1 T plus 1 times we return and
this this happens after t plus 1 over p1
steps in experiences and this is
actually even just to see x 1 with
probability 1 minus 2 to the minus T
requires roughly this number of steps so
we couldn't really hope to get a small
and much smaller number of samples is
optimal with respect to the number of
samples just to see where the nearest
neighbor and up to a constant
so you can apply this to nearest
neighbor and now I'm just assuming that
we have these data structures that each
of them gives us the nearest neighbor
with some probability and they give us
other points with with some probability
that is not not slaughter than the
nearest neighbor and so it's assuming
that someone gives us this series of
data structures then we can query the
optimal number of such data structures
depending on on p1 without actually
knowing p1 so the number of data
structures that we're going to to to to
query is Darwin or Delta divided by p1
so what does this mean it means that if
we want to find the nearest neighbor it
basically points boils down to
constructing these data structures such
that the product of the time and 1 over
p1 is minimized
maybe you can think about these data
stories as having a head time party at
all so how much time do I do I allow
them to to choo-choos vent and given
this time budget they need to maximize
the probability of actually finding the
diversity
and one question here that I'm not going
to answer today is that is whether you
can do construct these data structures
optimally without actually knowing the
distance to the nearest neighbor so most
of the literature on this on this
problem assumes that you have a
particular radius that you're interested
in searching and that simplifies a lot
of things so what we did do so though we
didn't find an answer to this question
we we did have yeah we did find a
partial answer for a particular Alice
age data structure called the SH forest
which is yeah it's it's a sequence of
space partitioning so each each tree
here in this forest is a recursive space
partitioning so you get space
partitioning at many levels of
granularity the further down in the tree
you go the the more fine-grained
partitioning that you have and for a
particular query if you have say you
have a query that is far from most of
the data points then a very coarse
partitioning is enough to actually not
have to to to look at too many many data
points if you if you have a query that
is quite close to a lot of data points
you might need to have a more
fine-grained partitioning okay so and
the standard query algorithm for SH
Forest is that you search a level of
these trees where the average number of
points you see in a petition is constant
so this is how you usually search SH
Forest and this you can show that this
works if the number of trees is high
enough but high enough actually depends
on the distance to the nearest neighbor
so it's not quite I mean even though
it's it claims to be kind of adaptive to
the to the particular query I mean it
does need to make some assumptions about
the distance to the nearest name
so what we can do instead is to modify
the query algorithms such that it's
actually also not just just search this
this level where the number of points is
it's constant on average but also
searches higher levels until
confirmation same thing tells us that we
can stop and we may also need to it
turns out that we also need to consider
partially searching a level so not
searching all the trees in a level but
also just searching a prefix of the
trees too to get the best results and
kind of roughly speaking what what we
can show is that if we do this then we
are competitive at least with the best
way of searching and LSH forest for the
given query so ok so even if we had if
we had kind of known ahead of time what
was what what what the position of the
query was respect to with respect to
true to the whole data set and we could
choose the optimal level and the optimal
number tree is based on that we can get
within like a constant factor in in
sciencebase
all right so I think the main open
question that that we have is really
whether we can find kind of a deal
adaptive data structure to work with
conformation sampling so the only what
we want is a method that is competitive
with the best LSH scheme that that is
tailored to both the query and the data
distribution so I can ask question about
the conformation sampling in order for
the results of work where you see the
nearest neighbor multiple times does
that need to be over the same family of
of hash functions or can you adaptively
change it or so so so actually so
actually everything works even if you
have a new if you sample from a new
distribution every time as long as you
can bound the probabilities so you could
you could in principle you know have use
different kinds of hash functions if you
wanted to
and the hope would would would be that
one could get kind of the optimal
probability of as achieve of returning
the actual nearest neighbor or in other
words instead of just looking at recall
as an empirical thing one could try to
get approval
Vanakkam results for expected recall so
that's all thank you very much questions
here everything was parametrized by the
p1 and p2 like the and of course you pay
for the fact that we look at it at the
bike it and then you need need to find
that closest element in the budget right
and ya know how in practice if this is
something that has high cost or not that
good is there did you see the Ananse
extended where you have the full pis and
then under some structure like all the P
is not there some structural assumption
on the dataset you can prove the base
quality quantity small I'm not sure I
got your question let's say that you're
only allowed to look at a certain number
of points in spite you don't want to
spend that time - yes so something that
could also because right now you know if
you have a very large budget this result
this still holds but if might you have
linearly you could do linear time oh
yeah yes but I think that's I mean given
the hardest research that's probably
unavoidable if you have a lot of if you
have like a cluster of points that are
very close to each other then nice I
don't think there's any way to actually
find the nearest point among those
points in unless that leniently nearly
linear time
I agree on that all I'm asking is
whether you can extend the analysis with
having some TI dependent bound that
takes into account the whole data set
that in the worst case of course will be
very bad we have that we have exactly
that yes I mean you can you can combine
it this with of a Lesage schemes and
right I mean give performance bounds
that depend on the distance distribution
so maybe that's maybe maybe that's what
you what you're asking yes that's that's
fine but just a some part online because
you mentioned that the hard cases of
there is a point which is close by but
if you think from a statistical
perspective like every collision is kind
of estimating the similar that p star
right so if you have a data then you can
actually estimate the you know you will
be you know or a long run you will
actually be estimating the frequency of
how many times I think so certainly if
you allow a log factor overhead you can
estimate P star very efficient very
precisely right right so the thing that
surprised me at least was that you don't
need to struggle with make overhead of
approximating collision probability but
you but you can actually to do something
that is optimal within constant factors
and also simpler
now what I was saying is that you can
actually like also is like question on
the data distribution you can actually
get what the rate of the submission
looks like by seeing what all you have
got how many times so I mean this one is
fine like you look at the confirmation
and then you are you retrieve the
neonate with 120 by the time you have
reads the confirmation you will if there
are very closeby points that you will
also be having a very good estimate for
those guys also yeah there must be a way
to say how much time you take is also
dependent on the reader and there is a
way to maybe characterize the data
distribution I got so I guess the taste
is a distribution mainly comes in with
respect to the amount of time it
actually takes to produce the samples
right I so if there's a lot of of points
that are almost the same distance as the
nearest neighbor then it's going to be
more expensive to produce the same you
get because for this you might be
getting t minus one for others right yes
but they only fail if if we get T
confirmations before seeing something
that's better so that's so do you may
not be the factor it may be like how
many distance computations you do so you
make it like lot of elements in one
market because there are more or less
similar so right so we didn't I delete
but that's that's right so there is a
cost of in terms of the number of
distance computations
do you see you could extend this to
Keener's yes so for K nearest neighbors
[Music]
there is that different ways of of doing
it so so I think the the simplest one is
basically to say that you need to have
all of them seems in all of them C minus
one times in that's okay I think that's
that can probably be improved a little
bit but but that's I mean that's
essentially it
[Applause]